du tambour du damier à la maison des
syndicats ce matin comme pour galvaniser
les troupes
avant de s'élancer dans les rues de la
capitale j'ai pas dit abou moulal rome à
guérande et mon staff électoral et la
nouvelle jetta bois encore une fois le
personnel de l'éducation nationale et
certains établissements de l'île ont
constitué le gros du contingent autour
de 2000 2500 personnes aujourd'hui dans
les rues également les représentera de
l'énergie aujourd'hui à nous les marquer
le coup d'habitude nous tes kablouti
entreprises là parce que tu as annoncé
meta qui est actionnaire à plus de 80 du
coussin avec dadaev donc jeudi à la cgt
demande et nous manquer le cou à des
mobilisations ville a donc nous fondons
mobilisés jeudi à pour que nous garder
mais j'aime spécial non et que tout les
nitrates pas changer d'échelon des
slogans et le même message politique à
l'adresse du gouvernement
nous refusons a totalement cette réforme
de la retraite parce que nous estimons
qu'aujourd'hui bon derrière cette
réforme de la retraite c'est la mise à
mal de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui alors
pour ceux qui sont concernés par la
retraite de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui en
situation de travail et qui avec leurs
tambours 0 lorsqu'ils seront à la
retraite je tenais plus aujourd'hui mon
4 lorsqu'on se rompt la retraite vous
changera une réelle diminution de leur
pension de retraite
7/10 manifestations depuis début
décembre est venu démontrer une chose
l'intersyndicale n'est pas encore prête
du tout à déposer les armes face au
gouvernement
[Musique]
buts hambourg du damier à la maison des
syndicats ce matin comme pour galvaniser
les troupes
avant de s'élancer dans les rues de la
capitale j'aime pas les dames où nous la
drôme à guérande et même davantage
d'oral et la nouvelle jetta bois encore
une fois le personnel de l'éducation
nationale et certains établissements de
l'île ont constitué le gros du
contingent autour de 2000 2500 personnes
aujourd'hui dans les rues également les
représentera de l'énergie aujourd'hui à
nous les marquer le coup d'habitude nous
tes kablouti entreprises là parce que
canon c'est l'état qui est actionnaire à
plus de 80 de coûts sont à l'adf donc je
dis à la cgt nous manquer le cou à des
mobilisations vue là donc nous fortement
mobilisés jeudi à pour nous gagner mais
j'aime spécialement et que toutes les
ni très plat changer d'échelon des
slogans et le même message politique à
l'adresse du gouvernement
nous refusons totalement cette réforme
de la retraite parce que nous estimons
qu'aujourd'hui bon derrière cette
réforme de la retraite c'est la mise à
mal de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui alors
pour ceux qui sont concernés par la
retraite de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
par auchan en situation de travail et
qui avec leurs tambours verront
lorsqu'ils seront à la retraite château
n'est plus aujourd'hui mon 4 lens nous
serons la retraite ce sera une réelle
diminution de leur pension de retraite
7/10 manifestations depuis début
décembre est venu démontrer une chose
l'intersyndicale n'est pas encore prête
du tout à déposer les armes face au
gouvernement
[Musique]